hi there Steve Kaufman here again and
today I want to talk about multitasking
and language learning but first if you
like these videos please subscribe to my
channel now I mentioned in my previous
video that I wanted to increase my
ability to notice things in Ukranian and
that therefore I was gonna be saving
phrases almost every phrase that contain
for example case endings a because just
even saving them helps me notice and B
because I can then review them in our
vocabulary section you know isolated by
a particular case so then I said well I
should try this in other languages so I
decided to choose Italian and in our
feed section of link we have we can see
articles that other people are studying
we can see newspaper articles which we
can import in the link so I chose one on
multitasking and I went through saving
phrases with tenses which sometimes
cause trouble in Italian I only need to
save that tense like tag it for a tense
I don't need a tag it for first second
or third person singular or plural
because if I capture the whole phrase
it'll be obvious who or what the subject
of that verb is so I was doing that but
of course the article was very
interesting and one of the delights of
language learning as you get past the
beginner stage is that you can actually
improve your language by reading or
listening to things that are interesting
so this article said multitasking is bad
it's bad for the brain and so I started
to think well what do they mean by
multitasking obviously if you're working
in an office and you're trying to do two
things at once you're going to be
distracted and probably that's bad for
the brain however when it comes to
language learning if I couldn't
multitask I don't think I would learn my
languages or it would take me much much
longer because probably 75% of my
learning activity is multitasking
primarily listening
I listen while exercising while driving
while doing the dishes and I'm almost
better able to concentrate while doing
some other relatively repetitive or call
it non thinking type tasks while
listening I may sometimes you know focus
in focus out but by and large I'm able
to get in 45 minutes a day an hour a day
of listening I look forward to doing the
dishes so that I can listen to my
language I then may concentrate sit down
and read and save phrases and work these
texts so that if I listen again I will
understand more and I will notice more
but it's very essential that I have this
ability to multitask and I think people
should develop that skill I sometimes
hear people say well I I can't focus
while I'm listening well maybe that's a
skill that you have to develop I can
even read on my iPad while I'm on my
treadmill and not a treadmill but I have
a stepper at home but I've seen people
on treadmills in health clubs who watch
TV programs while they're jogging so
there are tasks that you can do in
combination with other more or less
repetitive tasks and for language
learning I would say that developing the
ability to multitask at least the
ability to listen and to focus 60 70 80
percent of the time while listening and
doing other relatively repetitive tasks
is an important skill and even the
ability to read while say exercising the
reading is more difficult obviously you
can't read and do the dishes you can't
read and drive but you can read and be
on a treadmill so that was just
something that I wanted to mention and
and also I wanted to close by saying
that this issue of saving phrases of
link I think it's extremely important
and perhaps that we don't emphasize
strongly enough just how crucial it is
because you learn so much
words it's very difficult to cover all
of these words in your flash guarding or
other review type activities but the
number of phrases you need in order to
capture the essential structures of a
language is much much smaller so that if
you can focus on phrases save those
phrases tag those phrases review those
phrases in the vocabulary section you're
going to get a real good handle on the
structure of the language and pick up a
lot of vocabulary along the way so I
might just do a separate video in the
future about how I actually do this at
any rate multitasking I believe in so
far as language is concerned is
important and it's a skill that we need
to develop if we're going to be
efficient language learners thank you
for listening bye for now
[Music]